bangladesh might just be the most
resilient country on the planet
once the poorest part of british india
it became the most deprived part of
pakistan before experiencing the
deadliest cyclone in human history
that was followed by a liberation war
famine numerous political coups and
assassinations and devastating natural
disasters
the important thing is that
we have developed our internal
capability to cope with many of these
disasters bangladesh had to do it for
its own survival
famously referred to as a basket case in
1971 by u.s government officials
including henry kissinger in per capita
terms it's now among the richest
countries in south asia surpassing india
in 2020
it's not so secret to economic success
is what experts call rmg ready-made
garments
every country in the world
started their industrial revolution with
rng be it london new york japan korea
china and now bangladesh
the need to fill factory floors has made
a positive impact on one group in
particular women
and that set bangladesh apart from other
muslim majority countries as well as
india
this is also a component of the
capitalist society that kind of promotes
individualism and that could be one
reason that a large number of women
came into work they did not want to be
changed as a domestic helping hand to
any households
but bangladesh might be a victim of his
own success
in 2026 the um will upgrade it from
least developed country status but this
will mean the loss of economic benefits
along with lasting bias towards women
islamic fundamentalist groups are no
real plans to move beyond low-end
manufacturing the rapid progress of
bangladesh could be at risk
august 15 1947 the great symbol of the
british empire came down for the last
time to be replaced by the banner of the
new indian government
the partition of india created two
dominions to separate muslim and
non-muslim populations
india and western east pakistan which
included modern-day bangladesh 14
million people were displaced because
they left their homes anywhere between
one and two million people hindus
muslims and sikhs
they died muslims had been murdered on
the way hindus and sikhs who had been
murdered by muslims people of our
generation the older generation has
almost died out so that's the very
tragic story of partition
[Music]
for over two decades the majority
bengali population in east pakistan was
ruled by a central government based in
west pakistan which spent the majority
of capital on its own development
so the bengali grievance was that bengal
was being deprived of of its legitimate
share in economic resources in the mid
1960s that came to a head through a
demand for regional autonomy which we
call the six point uh program we in
bangladesh called it our magna carta
because from the sixth point onward we
went to one point which was independence
but before obtaining independence in
1970 the deadliest cyclone in human
history took place
in which up to 500 000 people died
there was no response from the pakistan
government no measures toward
rehabilitation toward coming to the to
the aid of those who survived uh coming
to locate the bodies or calculate the
damage that had been done
this accelerated the call for
independence and during the first
democratic election in pakistan the
awami league party led by sheikh mujibar
rahman won a decisive majority
legally i am the authority because
people have voted to me
now they are using their force it is up
to them now to decide what to do
not wanting pakistan to be ruled from
the east the central government in west
pakistan took military action
on the 25th of march the pakistan army
launched what has come to be known as
operation searchlight it's estimated
that on the on the very first night
between 5000 and 7000 people were killed
on the streets of dhaka and in the
course
of more than nine months the the
estimates put out by the government of
bangladesh is that three million people
were killed
the killings which bangladesh calls
genocide were followed by a liberation
war between east and west pakistan
10 million refugees fled to india while
the massacres continued and hundreds of
thousands died
it was india that came to the rescue
an india bangladesh joint command was
formed and very briskly very swiftly
they conquered the captured ever larger
slices of territory in east pakistan and
that was when the
people's republic of bangladesh was born
although bangladesh was newly
independent after years of turmoil it
was the second poorest nation in the
world and things were about to get worse
industry is at a halt
paraffin needed for cooking and heating
is very scarce and huge queues form for
any supply that becomes available
in its first four years the newly
independent nation was plagued by
mismanagement and food shortages that
led to a disastrous famine in which an
estimated 1.5 million people died but
then the tragedy again another tragedy
sheikh muji was assassinated by a group
of junior military officers he and most
of his family were killed
despite political instability coups and
assassinations the 80s saw rapid
economic improvements
there has been a sequence of reforms
that has initiated the private
sector-led
growth in bangladesh
you have to keep in mind bangladesh has
started the socialist country it
nationalized everything from banks to
all kinds of factories manufacturing and
so on the outcome was not very good
and the government realized it and
slowly started going back to the market
mechanism allowed the private sector to
come in which is the most important
thing
at the same time positive changes
initiated by ngos were embraced by the
government
like brac a non-profit created to help
those in need after the liberation war
on grumman bank the so-called bank for
the poor it gives millions in small
loans to the impoverished without
requiring collateral
97 of its borrowers are women
bangladesh being one of the
poorest countries in the world it was
also a ground for experimentation
for social development
this ngo sector are supported by the
government and also international
community i must say that the donor
community played a big role also in
supporting the drive that that was
led by the government and the result is
that
in a lot of social innovation social
engineering
bangladesh has pioneered
and and established shareable records
for development which is being
experimented or applied in parts of
africa latin america and other countries
this is a something something that we
feel proud of
[Music]
although foreign a played a big role in
the development of bangladesh accounting
for up to eight percent of their gross
national income in the seventies it's
now less than two percent
life expectancy has jumped from 47 to 73
years
bangladesh's female literacy rate is
higher than india's while its infant
mortality rate is lower
compared with the birth rate of a muslim
majority country in comparison with
india we are better off our birth rate
has come down family planning has been
adapted at every family level in
bangladesh more or less and there is no
taboo about it there is no religious
barrier against it why because of the
ngo movement because of awareness
because of government's
role in that also donor support usaid
has played a very significant role in in
popularizing
what i called
family planning in bangladesh so we have
to admit that international communities
role domestic effort and the government
all work together to bring about the
changes and that's why
bangladesh's population
now is almost at the replacement level
another significant shift for bangladesh
was the birth of a new local industry
inspired by the success of countries
like vietnam and china in exporting
clothes abroad bangladesh began to build
its own factories creating a new
entrepreneurial class
it's the low cost
starting point
because bangladeshis didn't have capital
we are not a capital rich country and
also didn't have the rich upper class
and so on and so forth so
most of them came from very ordinary
middle class background and became
entrepreneurs became self-made
it started
like a very small enterprise operation
and now they are big time players
and supplying globally
[Music]
i started the garden factory very small
canyon factory uh in city centers
now of course vltx group is one of the
very renowned group we have almost
fifteen thousand workforce i'm sure it
is very surprising that we are designing
product for the top brand in the world
everything we do that means not only the
garment manufacturing the enter process
we we call ourselves end-to-end solution
providers we have six
seven garment manufacturing plant we
produce roughly 3 million
neet garments every month and more than
1.5 million woven shirts every month
today the garment industry accounts for
up to 80 percent of the country's total
exports
part of its success is due to government
initiatives like the export development
fund
created in 1989 it allows exporters to
borrow at lower interest rates
and bangladesh's status as an ldc or
least developed country gives it
tax-free access to european markets to
boost trade and economic growth
also as china moves away from low-end
manufacturing towards higher end
products like cars bangladesh has been
able to benefit
[Music]
but perhaps the biggest beneficiaries of
the garment industry are women who had
previously been unable to make
dependable salaries
when this garment business started
somehow we able to attract this woman or
female workforce to our industry and
that can help significantly into our uh
i mean society just imagine i mean more
than 5 million
workforce 3 million women
average salaries for workers in the
ready-made garment industry are double
the country's minimum wage which means
that women can become financially
independent
in the rural areas there are not that
much
employment available so the women they
took off from the rural areas that no
they need to
search for better employment another
sociological thing is that the
emancipation that they could live by
themselves even though their salary was
quite meager they also have their mind
of their own if they were working within
someone's house they did not have any
vacation
no festival bonus given no you know
policies at least in the government
sectors uh gradually the policies came
into play so they could get a bonus
over time and a health security and
other issues
high rate of participation in bangladesh
could be
correlated with the free education for
girls at the secondary level you know
free stipend is given we have a very
strong ngo based communities and the
civil society who actually looked into
this and encouraged women's
you know participation
since first serving as prime minister in
1996 sheikh hasina daughter of the first
elected president of bangladesh has also
introduced laws to balance out the
treatment of men and women
when this hasina shakar came into power
she herself took a lot of positive steps
for women's empowerment particularly
involving women in income generating
activities encouraging women to remain
in the rmg sectors and provided lot of
facilities like daycares she actually
was the first prime minister that
introduced the national policies for the
advancement of women in 1997
and there actually she directly
mentioned in the policy that women
should be given equal inheritance to
property rights
but even though great progress has been
made women in bangladesh are still not
treated as equals
women still seen as the second class
citizen the way the patriarchal society
and the men and the suicide family and
the state perceives is that women need
to be controlled there are very few
women in the highest level of decision
making even in the administrative sector
even in the police
you know navy
military
women are actually at the bottom of the
hierarchy
there are also religious parties in the
country that demand the imposition of
islamic laws which would threaten the
rights of women and the economy that
depends on them to work
so even though the religious preachers
they say things about certain rules and
norms and customs women have to follow
when they go
now for work uh they have never said
that
like broadly you know why the firm that
women cannot work
and bangladesh it's it's uh of course
the secularism this pillar of one of the
strongest pillar of our constitution
while a thriving industry has helped
grow bangladesh's economy and empower
women a big problem remains abysmal
working conditions
of course along the way they've been
tragedies
for example a few years ago there was
called this rana plaza tragedy between
fires taking place occurring in
other garment industries so those have
been
accidents tragic accidents which we as a
nation regret and which we feel will not
be happening anymore
after the rana plaza tragedy where over
1 000 people died nearly 200
international brands signed an agreement
that allowed for legally binding safety
commitments independent inspections at
the factories and contributions for
safety training and factory improvements
a renewal agreement was signed in 2021
[Music]
the government industry has been a boost
for bangladesh's economy i think
we we got the idea of improving of uh
going on to other areas and of course
exporting our goods abroad so we have
our sense of optimism there but then
again we're very cautious about the
future
exporting abroad could now be easier
with the recent completion of the padma
bridge now the longest in bangladesh
that links the less developed southwest
with the rest of the country
it offers a faster route to the second
largest port for exporters shipping to
europe
if you put a ladder and climb it up as
development goes up
we are still in the first step of the
ladder we have not yet
broadened
the
export base
to move up the ladder we needed to move
to light engineering we needed to move
to electronics
government should play the enabling role
and make the playing field even for all
sectors
not only for the governments
if they can do that
i think
we can see
the
winners which will come out of the
market forces
as bangladesh graduates from least
developed country status the loss of
economic benefits will put pressure on
its economy
unless the government can sign
tariff-free trade agreements tackle
corruption and diversify its economy the
goal of reaching upper middle income
status by 2031 may not be met
[Music]
you